at this altitude I can this episode is
brought to you by teeter I am so
thrilled to have connected with these
guys because I've used teeter products
for many many years I've traveled around
the country and the world with Teeter
products and I'm sitting about 15 feet
in my home from one of their inversion
tables and we're gonna talk more about
all of that one of my rituals is hanging
and I should say not really that it's a
maintenance and performance program I
hang not just in the morning potentially
but particularly after a day of bearing
weight whether that includes weight
training in Jersey Greg rec world
record-holder
insists on this type of inversion
therapy after training or just wearing
heavy backpack around a few minutes goes
a long way towards better sleep in my
case less back pain neck pain leg pain
it's not a panacea obviously but
inversion therapy which uses gravity in
your own bodyweight to decompress the
spine and relieve pressure on the discs
and surrounding nerves seems to help
with a whole slew of conditions and just
as a general maintenance program it's
one of my favorite things to do so what
to say about that Teeter why Teeter
Teeter is the best known name in
inversion table since 1981 more than 3
million people have put their trust in
Teeter Teeter is also the only inversion
table brand that has been both safety
certified by Underwriters Laboratories
that's ul for you people in that
industry you will recognize it and
registered with the FDA as a class 1
medical device and they're giving a very
special offer just to you guys my
listeners for a limited time you can get
the teeter inversion table with bonus
accessories which I have a bunch of
again in the room next to me and a free
pair of gravity boots so that you can
invert at home or take the boots with
you to the gym so these gravity boots I
have three
separate pairs of gravity boots bought
with my own money z' in three different
cities that I've had for a very very
long time because I don't want to travel
with them necessarily it look kind of
like ski boots but without the foot
portion and they hook you upside down so
you can take them really anywhere you
want to go to get this deal which is a
savings of over a hundred and forty
eight dollars it's very specific so
maybe it's a hundred forty nine you have
to go to Teeter comm forward slash Tim
that's Teeter comm forward slash Tim te
ter you also see a free shipping a sixty
day money back guarantee end free
returns so why not try it out remember
you can only get the teeter inversion
table with bonus accessories and a free
pair of gravity boots by going to Teeter
comm forward slash Tim so if you think
of yourself what the hell is this thing
he's talking about I can't even envision
it in my head well take a look at the
photos go to Teeter dot-com forward
slash Tim hello boys and girls and
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show this is Tim Ferriss and
each and every episode it is typically
my job to deconstruct world-class
performers and long-form interviews
whether they come from the world of
military entertainment sports investing
business or otherwise this episode is
going to be a special intervention /
helping hand as much for me as anyone
else from the outside looking in the
last two to four weeks have been
disaster after disaster for me I had a
very unexpected and sad death in the
family
several large business deals that were
in process for six plus months fell
apart at the last minute and the list
just goes on and on and on I may in fact
have to sue someone for breach of
contract which I'm always loathe to do
and it's been high stress it has been
high stress and the question then is how
does one respond when faced with the
unpredictable one of the tools is a book
there are several books that I've
thought about over and over again during
this period one of them is the obstacle
is the way by ryan holiday
find them on Twitter at Ryan holiday it
has helped me to look at problems
differently turn them upside down become
the calm within the storm and even
uncover unique opportunities believe it
or not so in many ways I've come to see
these problems that have assaulted me
these situations that have surprised me
as blessings in disguise
in some cases the obstacle is the way as
I mentioned by Ryan holiday is a
collection of stories and principles
about stoicism which is not a cow
standing in the rain that's not what you
want to become it is what I consider to
be the ultimate personal operating
system let's say for anyone who wants to
thrive in high stress environments and
situations if you want to be anti
fragile like Thomas Jefferson say Marcus
Aurelius Bill Belichick and many of the
most dominant investors in history
stoicism offers a real playbook and is
in fact part of the playbook or play
books of everyone I just mentioned if
you want to make better decisions if you
want to smile when other people cower it
offers very very pragmatic approaches
and it's not panacea you are most
certainly going to feel certain types of
emotions that maybe you prefer not to
you
the question is how do you then react
how do you then respond to quote Andy
Grove former CEO of Intel quote bad
companies are destroyed by crisis good
companies survive them great companies
are improved by them so what if you
could be a person who is improved by
crisis at the very least I suspect it
would give you opportunities no one else
can see let alone grasp much more
important in my mind at this point it
would make you a happier and much more
at peace human being and the content of
the four sample chapters that are going
to comprise this episode are very
closely related to my last TED talk
about an exercise called fear setting
which I do I would say these days every
week put more typically every month it
is the most important and valuable
exercise that I do and you can hear
about that and also see a text version
of it at Tim blog forward slash Ted and
this book the obstacles the way is part
of the Tim Ferriss book club which is
in hibernation but there are still about
ten of the books that you can see
audible.com forward slash Tim's books
the top is a little bit stoicism heavy
so you can scroll down to see other
books about travel and rituals and
routines of successful people and so on
so if that is of interest you can check
it out audible.com forward slash Tim's
books but in the meantime I hope that
this is an episode that you find helpful
or perhaps return to during times of
stress when you're caught off guard and
with that without further ado please
enjoy the obstacle is the way by Ryan
holiday control your emotions
would you have a great Empire rule over
yourself
Publius Cirrus when America raised to
send the first men into space they
trained the astronauts in one skill more
than any other the art of not panicking
when people panic they make mistakes
they override systems they disregard
procedures and ignore rules they deviate
from the plan they become unresponsive
and stop thinking clearly
they just react not to what they need to
react to but to the survival hormones
that are coursing through their veins
welcome to the source of most of the
problems down here on earth everything
is planned down to the letter then
something goes wrong and the first thing
we do is trade in our plan for a good ol
emotional freakout some of us almost
crave sounding the alarm because it's
easier than dealing with whatever is
staring us in the face at a hundred and
fifty miles above Earth in a spaceship
smaller than a VW this is death panic is
suicide so the panic has to be trained
out and it does not go easily before the
first launch NASA recreated the fateful
day for the astronauts over and over
step-by-step hundreds of times from what
they'd have for breakfast to the ride to
the airfield
slowly and graded series of exposures
the astronauts were introduced to every
sight and sound of the experience of
their firing into space they did it so
many times that it became as natural and
familiar as breathing
they'd practice all the way through
holding nothing back but the liftoff
itself making sure to solve for every
variable and remove all uncertainty
uncertainty and fear are relieved by
Authority training is Authority it's a
release valve with enough exposure you
can adapt out those perfectly ordinary
even innate fears that are bred mostly
from unfamiliarity fortunately
unfamiliarity is simple to fix again not
easy which makes it possible to increase
our tolerance for stress and uncertainty
John Glenn the first American astronaut
to orbit the earth spent nearly a day in
space still keeping this heartrate
100 beats per minute that's a man not
simply sitting at the controls but in
control of his emotions a man who had
properly cultivated what Tom Wolfe later
called the right stuff but you confront
a client or a stranger on the street and
your heart is liable to burst out of
your chest or called on to address a
crowd and your stomach crashes through
the floor it's time to realize that this
is a luxury and indulgence of our lesser
self in space the difference between
life and death lies in emotional
regulation hitting the wrong button
reading the instrument panels
incorrectly engaging the sequence too
early none of these could have been
afforded on a successful Apollo mission
the consequences were too great thus the
question for astronauts was not how
skilled a pilot are you but can you keep
an even strain can you fight the urge to
panic and instead focus only on what you
can change on the task at hand life is
really no different obstacles make us
emotional but the only way we'll survive
or overcome them is by keeping those
emotions in check if we can keep steady
no matter what happens no matter how
much external events may fluctuate the
Greeks had a word for this apatheia it's
the kind of emotional equanimity that
comes from the absence of irrational or
extreme emotions not the loss of feeling
altogether just the loss of the harmful
unhelpful kind
don't let the negativity in don't let
those emotions even get started just say
no thank you
I can't afford to panic this is the
skill that must be cultivated freedom
from disturbance and perturbation so you
can focus your energy exclusively on
solving problems rather than reacting to
them a boss is urgent email an [ __ ]
in a bar a call from the bank your
financing has been pulled a knock at the
door there's been an accident as Gavin
de Becker writes in the gift of fear
when you worry ask yourself what am i
choosing to not see right now what
important things are you missing because
you chose worry over introspection
alertness or wisdom another way of
putting it does getting upset provides
you with more options sometimes it does
but in this instance no I suppose not
well then if an emotion can't change the
condition or the situation you're
dealing with it is likely an unhelpful
emotion or quite possibly a destructive
one but it's what I feel right no one
said anything about not feeling it no
one ever said you can't cry forget
manliness if you need to take a moment
by all means go ahead real strength lies
in the control or as the seem to let put
it the domestication of one's emotions
not in pretending they don't exist so go
ahead feel it just don't lie to yourself
by conflating a moding about a problem
with dealing with it because they are as
different as sleeping and waiting you
can always remind yourself I am in
control not my emotions I see what is
really going on here I am NOT going to
get excited or upset we defeat emotions
with logic or that's the idea logic is
questions and statements with enough of
them we get two root causes which are
always easier to deal with we lost money
but aren't losses a pretty common part
of business yes are these losses
catastrophic not necessarily so this is
not totally unexpected is it how could
that be so bad why are you all worked up
over something that is at least
occasionally supposed to happen
well I and not only that but you've
dealt with the worse situations than
this wouldn't you be better off applying
some of that resourcefulness rather than
anger try having that conversation with
yourself and see how these extreme
emotions hold up they won't last long
trust that after all you are probably
not going to die from any of this it
might help to say it over and over again
whenever you feel the anxiety begin to
come on I'm not going to die from this
I'm not going to die from this I am NOT
going to die from this
or try Marcus's question does what
happened keep you from acting with
justice generosity self-control sanity
prudence honesty humility
for word nests nope then get back to
work
subconsciously we should be constantly
asking ourselves this question do I need
to freak out about this and the answer
like it is for astronauts for soldiers
for doctors and for so many other
professionals must be no because I
practiced for this situation and I can
control myself or no because I caught
myself and I'm able to realize that it
doesn't add anything constructive
finding the opportunity
a good person dies events with his own
color and turns whatever happens to his
benefit Seneca
one of the most intimidating and
shocking developments in modern warfare
was the German blitzkrieg or lightning
war in World War two the Germans wanted
to avoid the drawn-out trench fighting
of previous Wars so they concentrated
mobile divisions into rapid narrow
offensive forces that caught their
enemies completely unprepared like the
tip of a spear columns of Panzer tanks
rushed into Poland the Netherlands
Belgium and France with devastating
results and little opposition in most
cases the opposing commander simply
surrendered rather than face what felt
like an invincible indefatigable monster
bearing down on them the blitzkrieg
strategy was designed to exploit the
flinch of the enemy he must collapse at
the site of what appears to be
overwhelming force its success depends
completely on this response this
military strategy works because the set
upon troops see the offensive force as
an enormous obstacle bearing down on
them this is how the Allied opposition
viewed the blitzkrieg for most of the
war they could see only its power and
their own vulnerability to it in the
weeks and months after the successful
invasion of Normandy by Allied forces
they faced it again a set of massive
German counter-offensives how could they
stop it would it throw them back into
the very beaches they just purchased
it's so high a cost a great leader
answered that question striding into a
conference room at the headquarters in
Malta General Dwight D Eisenhower made
an announcement he'd have no more of
this quivering timidity from his
deflated generals the present situation
is to be regarded as an opportunity for
us and not disaster he commanded there
will only be cheerful faces at this
conference table in that surgeon
counter-offensive Eisenhower was able to
see the tactical solution that had been
in front of them the entire time that
the Nazis strategy carried its own
destruction within itself only then when
the Allies able to see the opportunity
inside the obstacle rather than simply
the obstacle that threatened them
properly seen as long as the Allies
could bend and not break this attacks at
more than fifty thousand Germans Russian
head first into a net or a meat grinder
as Patton eloquently put it the Battle
of the Bulge and before that the Battle
of the fall as pocket
which both were feared to be major
reversals and end of the Allies momentum
in fact were their greatest triumphs by
allowing a forward wedge of the German
army through and then attacking from the
sides
the Allies encircled the enemy
completely from the rear the invincible
penetrating thrust of the German Panzers
wasn't just impotent but suicidal a
textbook example of why you never leave
your flanks exposed more important it's
a textbook example of the rule our own
perceptions play in the success or
failures of those who oppose us it's one
thing to not be overwhelmed by obstacles
or discouraged or upset by them this is
something that few are able to do but
after you have controlled your emotions
and you can see objectively and stand
steadily the next step becomes possible
a mental flip so you're looking not at
the obstacle but if the opportunity
within it as Laura Ingalls Wilder put in
there is good at everything if only we
look for it
yet we are so bad at looking we close
our eyes to the gift imagine if you'd
been in Eisenhower's shoes with an army
racing towards you and you'd seen only
impending defeat how much longer would
the war have gone on how many more lives
lost
it's our preconceptions that are the
problem they tell us that things should
or need to be a certain way so when
they're not we naturally assume we are
at a disadvantage or that we'd be
wasting our time to pursue an alternate
course when really it's all fair game
and every situation is an opportunity
for us to act let's take a circumstance
we've all been in having a bad boss all
we see is the hell all we see is the
thin bearing down on us we flinch but
what if you regarded it as an
opportunity instead of a disaster if you
meet it when you say you're at the end
of your rope and you would rather quit
you actually have an opportunity to
change and grow and improve yourself a
unique opportunity to experiment with
different solutions to try different
tactics or to take on new projects to
add to your skill set you could study
this bad boss and learn from him while
you fill out your resumes and hit up
contacts for a better job elsewhere you
could prepare yourself for that job by
trying
styles of communication or standing up
for yourself all with a perfect safety
net for yourself quitting and getting
out of there with this new attitude and
fearlessness who knows you might be able
to exact concessions and find that you
like the job again
one day the boss will make a mistake and
then you'll make your move and
outmaneuver him it will feel so much
better than the alternative
whining bad-mouthing duplicity
spinelessness or take that longtime
rival at work or that rival company the
one who causes endless headaches note
the fact that they keep you alert raise
the stakes motivate you to prove them
wrong harden you help you appreciate
your friends provide an instructive
answer log the example of who you don't
want to become or that computer glitch
that erased all your work you will now
be twice as good at it since you will do
it again how about that business
decision that turned out to be a mistake
well you had a hypothesis and it turned
out to be wrong why should that upset
you it wouldn't piss off a scientist it
would help him maybe don't bet so much
on it next time and now you've learned
two things that your instinct was wrong
and the kind of appetite for risk you
really have blessings and burdens are
not mutually exclusive it's a lot more
complicated Socrates had a mean nagging
wife she always said that being married
to her was good practice for philosophy
of course you'd want to avoid something
negative if you could but what if you
were able to remember in the moment the
second act that seems to come with the
unfortunate situations we try so hard to
avoid sports psychologists recently did
a study of elite athletes who were
struck with some adversity or serious
injury initially each reported feeling
isolation emotional disruption and
doubts about their athletic ability yet
afterwards each reported gaining a
desire to help others additional
perspective and a realization of their
own strength in other words every fear
doubt they felt during the injury turned
into greater abilities in those exact
areas it's a beautiful idea
psychologists call it adversarial growth
and post-traumatic growth that which
doesn't kill me makes me stronger is not
a cliche but fact the struggle against
an
chuckle inevitably propels the fighter
to a new level of functioning the extent
of the struggle determines the extent of
the growth the obstacle is an advantage
not adversity the enemy is any
perception that prevents us from seeing
this of all the strategies we talked
about this is the one you can always use
everything can be flipped seen with this
kind of gaze a piercing look that
ignores the package and sees only the
gift or we can fight it the entire way
the result is the same the obstacle
still exists one just hurts less the
benefit is still there below the surface
what kind of idiot decides not to take
it now the things that other people
avoid or flinch away from we're thankful
for when people are rude or
disrespectful well that means they
underestimate us a huge advantage
connivin well we won't have to apologize
when we make an example out of them
critical or question our abilities lower
expectations are easier to exceed lazy
makes whatever we accomplish seem all
the more admirable its striking these
are perfectly fine starting points
better in some cases than whatever you'd
have hoped for in the best case scenario
what advantaged you derive from someone
being polite we're pulling their punches
behind the behaviors that provoke an
immediate negative reaction is an
opportunity some exposed benefit that we
can seize mentally and then act upon so
focus on that on the poorly wrapped and
initially repulsive present you've been
handed in every seemingly
disadvantageous situation because
beneath the packaging is what we need
often something of real value a gift of
great benefit no one is talking glass
half full style platitudes here this is
a complete flip seat through the
negative past its underside and into its
corollary the positive
follow the process
under the comb the tangle and the
straight path are the same Heraclitus
coach Nick say
doesn't actually refer to it very often
but every one of his assistants and
players live by it they say it for him
tattooing it at the front of their minds
and on every action they take because
just two words are responsible for their
unprecedented success the process Sabin
the head coach of the University of
Alabama football team perhaps the most
dominant dynasty in the history of
college football doesn't focus on what
every other coach focuses on or at least
not the way they do he teaches the
process the process and his words don't
think about winning the SEC championship
don't think about the national
championship think about what you needed
to do in this drill on this play in this
moment that's the process let's think
about what we can do today the task at
hand
chaos of sport as in life process
provides us away it says okay
you've got to do something very
difficult don't focus on that instead
break it down into pieces simply do what
you need to do right now and do it well
and then move on to the next thing
follow the process and not the prize the
road to back-to-back championships is
just that a road and you travel along a
road in steps excellence is a matter of
steps excelling at this one and then
that one and then the one after that
Saban's process is exclusively this
existing in the present taking it one
step at a time not getting distracted by
anything else not the other team not the
scoreboard or the crowd the process is
about finishing finishing games
finishing workouts finishing film
sessions finishing drives finishing reps
finishing plays finishing blocks
finishing the smallest tasks you have
right in front of you and finishing it
well whether it's pursuing the pinnacle
of success in your field or simply
surviving some awful or trying ordeal
the same approach works don't think
about the end think about surviving
making it from meal the meal break to
break checkpoint to checkpoint
paycheck-to-paycheck one day at a time
and when you really get it right even
the hardest things become manageable
because the process is relaxed in under
its influence we needn't panic even
mammoth tasks become just a series of
component parts
this was what the great 19th century
pioneer of meteorology James Pollard SP
had shown to him in a chance encounter
as a young man unable to read and write
until he was 18
SB attended a rousing speech by the
famous orator Henry Clay after the talk
the spellbound SB tried to make his way
towards Clay but couldn't form the words
to speak to his idol one of his friends
shouted out for him he wants to be like
you
even though he can't read clay grabbed
one of his posters which had the word
clay written in big letters
he looked at SB and said you see that
boy pointing to a letter that's an A now
you've only got 25 more letters to go SB
had just been gifted the process within
a year she started college I know that
seems almost too simple but envisioned
for a second a master practising an
exceedingly difficult craft and making
it look effortless there's no strain no
struggle so relaxed no exertion or worry
just one clean movement after another
that's a result of the process we can
channel this too we needn't scramble
like we're so often inclined to do when
some difficult task sits in front of us
remember the first time you saw a
complicated algebra equation it was just
a jumble of symbols and unknowns but you
then stopped took a deep breath and
broke it down you isolated the variables
solve for them and all that's left was
the answer do that now for whatever
obstacles you come across we can take a
breath do the immediate composite part
in front of us and follow its thread
into the next action everything in order
everything connected
when it comes to our actions disorder
and distraction or death the unordered
mind loses track of what's in front of
it what matters and gets distracted by
thoughts of the future the processes
order it keeps our perceptions in check
and our actions in sync it seems obvious
but we forget this when it matters most
right now if I knocked you down and
pinned you to the ground how would you
respond
you'd probably panic and then you'd push
with all your strength to get me off you
it wouldn't work
just using my bodyweight I would be able
to keep your shoulders against the
ground with little effort and you'd grow
exhausted fighting it that's the
opposite of the process there's a much
easier way first you don't panic you
conserve your energy you don't do
anything stupid like get yourself choked
out by acting without thinking you focus
on not letting it get worse then you get
your arms up to brace and create some
breathing room some space now work to
get to your side from there you can
start to break down my hold on you grab
an arm trap a leg buck with your hips
and slide in a knee and push away it'll
take some time but you'll get yourself
out at each step the person on top is
forced to give a little up till there's
nothing left then you're free thanks to
the process
being trapped is just a position not a
faith you get out of it by addressing
and eliminating each part of that
position through small deliberate action
not by trying and failing to push it
away with superhuman strength with our
business rivals we wrap our brains that
think of some mind-blowing new product
that will make them all irrelevant and
in the process we take our eye off the
ball we shy away from writing a book or
making a film even though it's our dream
because it's so much work we can't
imagine how to get from here to there
how often do we compromise or settle
because we feel that the real solution
is too ambitious or outside our grasp
how often do we assume that change is
impossible because it's too big involves
too many different groups or worse how
many people are paralyzed by all their
ideas and inspirations they chase them
all and go nowhere distracting
themselves and never making headway
they're brilliant sure but they rarely
execute they rarely get where they want
and need to go all of these issues are
solvable each would collapse beneath the
process we've just wrongly assumed that
it all has to happen at once and we give
up at the thought of it we are a twosie
thinkers fretting about a obsessing over
Z yet forgetting all about B through
what we want to have goals yes so
everything we do can be in service of
something purposeful when we know what
we are really setting out to do the
obstacles that arise tend to seem
smaller and more manageable
when we don't each one looms larger and
seems impossible goals help us put the
blips and bumps in their proper
proportion when we get distracted when
we start caring about something other
than our own progress and efforts the
process is the helpful if occasionally
bossy voice in our head it is the bark
of the wise older leader who knows
exactly who he is and what he's got to
do shut up go back to your stations try
to think about what we are going to do
ourselves instead of worrying about
what's going on out there you know what
your job is stop John and get to work
the process is the voice that demands we
take responsibility and ownership that
prompts us to act even if only in a
small way like a relentless machine
subjugating resistance each and every
way it exists
little by little moving forward one step
at a time
subordinate strength to the process
replace fear with the process depend on
it lean on it trust in it take your time
don't rush some problems are harder than
others
deal with the ones right in front of you
first come back to the others later
you'll get there the process is about
doing the right things right now not
worrying about what might happen later
or the results or the whole picture love
everything that happens amor fati
by formula for greatness and a human
being is a more fatty that one wants
nothing to be different not forward not
backward not in all eternity not merely
bear what is necessary
still less conceal it but love it
Nietzsche at age 67 Thomas Edison
returned home early one evening from
another day at the laboratory
shortly after dinner a man came rushing
into his house with urgent news a fire
had broken out at Edison's research and
production campus a few miles away fire
engines from the eight nearby towns
rushed to the scene but they could not
contain the blaze fueled by the strange
chemicals in the various buildings green
and yellow flames shot up six and seven
stories threatening to destroy the
entire empire Edison had spent his life
building Edison calmly but quickly made
his way to the fire through the now
hundreds of onlookers and devastated
employees looking for his son go get
your mother and all her friends he told
his son with childlike excitement
they'll never see a fire like this again
what don't worry
Edison calmed him it's all right we've
just got rid of a lot of rubbish that's
a pretty amazing reaction but when you
think about it there really was no other
response
what should a dicent have done wet
gotten angry quit and gone home what
exactly would that have accomplished you
know the answer now it's nothing so we
didn't waste time indulging himself to
do great things we need to be able to
endure tragedy and setbacks we've got to
love what we do and all that it entails
good and bad we have to learn to find
joy in every single thing that happens
because there was a little more than
rubbish in Edison's buildings years and
years of priceless records prototypes
and research were turned to ash the
buildings which had been made of what
was supposedly fireproof concrete had
been insured for only a fraction of
their worth thinking that they were
immune to such disasters Edison and his
investors were covered for about a third
of the damage
still Edison wasn't heartbroken not as
he could've and probably should have
been instead it all invigorated him as
he told a reporter the next day he
wasn't too old to make a fresh start
I've been through a lot of things like
this he said it prevents a man from
being afflicted with unweave within
about three weeks the factory was
partially back up and running within a
month its men were working two shifts a
day churning out new products of the
world had never seen despite a loss of
almost 1 million dollars more than 23
million in today's dollars and it's
inward Marshall enough energy to make
nearly 10 million dollars in revenue
that year two hundred plus million
dollars today he not only suffered a
spectacular disaster but he recovered
and replied to it spectacularly the next
step after we discard our expectations
and accept what happens to us after
understanding that certain things
particularly bad things are outside our
control is this loving whatever happens
to us and facing it with unfailing
cheerfulness it is the act of turning
what we must do into what we get to do
we put our energies and emotions and
exertions where they will have real
impact this is that place we will tell
ourselves this is what I've got to do or
put up with well I might as well be
happy about it here's an image to
consider the great boxer Jack Johnson
and his famous 15 round brawl with Jim
Jefferies Jefferies the great white hope
called out of retirement like some
deranged Cincinnatus to defeat the
ascendant black champion and Johnson
genuinely hated by his opponent in the
crowd still enjoying every minute of it
smiling joking playing the whole fight
why not there's no value in any other
reaction should he hate them for hating
him bitterness was their burden and
Johnson refused to pick it up not that
he simply took the abuse instead Johnson
designed his fight plan around it at
every nasty remark from Geoffrey's
corner he
his opponent another lesen at every low
trick or rush from Jeffries Johnson
would quip and beat it back but never
lose his cool and when one well-placed
blow opened the cut on Johnson's lip he
kept smiling a gory bloody but
nevertheless cheerful smile every round
he got happier friendlier as his
opponent grew enraged tired eventually
losing the will to fight in your worst
moments picture Johnson always calm
always in control genuinely loving the
opportunity to prove himself to perform
for people whether they wanted him to
succeed or not each remark bringing the
response it deserved and no more letting
the opponent dig his own grave until the
fight ended with Jeffries on the floor
and every doubt about Johnson silenced
as Jack London the famous novelist
reported from the inside seats no one
understands him this man who smiles
while the story of the fight is the
story of a smile if ever a man won by
nothing more fatiguing than a smile
Johnson won today that man is us or
rather it can be us if we strive to
become like him for we're in our own
fight with our own obstacles and we can
wear them down with our relentless smile
frustrating the people or impediments
attempting to frustrate us we can be
Edison or Factory on fire not by moaning
our fade but enjoying the spectacular
scene and then starting the recovery
effort the very next day roaring back
soon enough your obstacle may not be so
serious or violent but they are
nevertheless significant and outside
your control they warrant only one
response a smile as the Stoics commanded
themselves cheerfulness in all
situations especially the bad ones who
knows where edison and johnson learned
this epigram but they clearly did
learning not to kick and scream about
matters we can't control is one thing
indifference and acceptance are
certainly better than disappointment or
rage very few understand or practice
that art but it is only a first step
better than all of that is love
for all that happens to us for every
situation the goal is not I'm okay with
this knot I think I feel good about this
but I feel great about it
because if it happened then it was meant
to happen and I am glad that it did when
it did I am meant to make the best of it
and proceed to do exactly that we don't
get to choose what happens to us but we
can always choose how we feel about it
and why on earth would you choose to
feel anything but good
we can choose to render a good account
of ourselves if the event must occur
amor fati a love of fate is the response
don't waste a second looking back at
your expectations face forward and face
it with a smug little grin it's
important to look at Johnson and Edison
because they weren't passive they didn't
simply roll over and tolerate adversity
they accepted what happened to them they
liked it it's a little unnatural I know
to feel gratitude for things we never
wanted to happen in the first place
but we know at this point the
opportunities and benefits that lay
within adversities we know that and
overcoming them we emerged stronger
sharper empowered there's little reason
to delay these feelings to boo
grudgingly acknowledged later that it
was for the best
when we could have felt that in advance
because it was inevitable you love it
because it's all fuel and you don't just
want fuel you need it you can't go
anywhere without it no one or no thing
can so you're grateful for it that is
not to say that the good will always
outweigh the bad or that it comes free
and without cost but there is always
some good even if only barely
perceptible at first contained within
the bad and we can find it and be
cheerful because of it
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
cheater I am so thrilled to have
connected with these guys because I've
used Titor products for many many years
I've traveled around the country and the
world with Titor products and I'm
sitting about 15 feet in my home from
one of their inversion tables and we're
gonna talk more about all of that one of
my rituals is hanging and I should save
not only that it's a maintenance and
performance program I hang not just in
the morning potentially but particularly
after a day of bearing weight whether
that includes weight training in Jersey
Greg rec world record holder insists on
this type of inversion therapy after
training or just wearing heavy backpack
around a few minutes goes a long way
towards better sleep in my case less
back pain neck pain leg pain it's not a
panacea obviously but inversion therapy
would uses gravity and your own
bodyweight decompress the spine and
weave
on the disks and surrounding nerves
seems to help with a whole slew of
conditions and just as a general
maintenance program it's one of my
favorite things to do so what to say
about that
Peter why Teeter Teeter is the best
known name in inversion table since 1981
more than three million people have put
their trust in Teeter Teeter is also the
only inversion table brand that has been
both safety certified by Underwriters
Laboratories at the UL few people in
that industry will recognize it and
registered with the FDA as a class 1
medical device and they're giving a very
special offer just to you guys my
listeners for a limited time you can get
the teeter inversion table with bonus
accessories which I have a bunch of
again in the room next to me and a free
pair of gravity boots so that you can
invert at home or take the boots with
you to the gym so these gravity boots I
have three separate pairs of gravity
boots bought with my own money
in three different cities than I've had
for a very very long time because I
don't want to travel with them
necessarily it look kind of like ski
boots but without the foot portion and
they hook you upside down so you can
take them really anywhere you want to go
to get this deal which is a savings of
over a hundred and forty eight dollars
it's very specific so maybe it's a
hundred and forty nine you have to go to
teeter calm forward-slash Tim that's
teeter calm focus on stem te e ter
you'll see a free shipping a sixty day
money-back guarantee and free returns so
why not try it out remember you can only
get the teeter inversion table with
bonus accessories and a free pair of
gravity boots by going to Teeter comm
forward slash Tim so if you're thinking
yourself what the hell is this thing
these talk about I can't even envision
it in my head well take a look at the
photos go to Teeter comm forward slash
tip
you
you